[Music]
millions of Americans live in distressed
communities where poverty rates are high
and levels of education and workforce
participation are low these areas face
many challenges but a big one is their
lack of access to capital these
communities have hopes and dreams but no
one is investing in them the new
opportunities own program can help it
had governors dozen a 25% of their low
income census tracts to be Opportunity
Zones
more than 8700 nationwide and it gave
investors tax incentives to funnel
capital into revitalization projects
there these projects can serve a variety
of needs from housing to business
investments but one of the biggest
opportunities is to strengthen the
backbone of many of these communities
education and workforce institutions
opportunity zone funds can finance new
child care facilities fund facilities
for equality charter schools or invest
in overlooked entrepreneurs this program
is the largest Community Development
initiative in a generation but its
success isn't guaranteed community
leaders policy makers and philanthropies
will have to work together to make these
investments pay off for their
communities have you heard about any
opportunity zone projects in your
neighborhood let us know in our poll but
also let us know what other topics you'd
like our scholars to cover in 60 seconds
and be sure to LIKE and subscribe for
more research and videos from AEI